et sarah vraiment bravo ma chérie parce
que c'est vrai que tu étais une immense
championne j'étais énormément suivi et
c'est vrai que le fait d'avoir brisé le
silence comme ce si long silence à fait
derrière que tu as libérer vraiment la
parole derrière c'est vrai qu'il y aura
un avant et un après sarah abitbol est
ce que tu en as conscience de ça oui
j'en ai conscience maintenant sur le
coup non parce que c'est vrai que
j'enchaînais beaucoup les télévisions et
je me rendais pas compte mais
aujourd'hui quand on voit avec le
ministère le nombre de personnes
tag raid agresseurs il ya environ 600
agresseur dans le sport imaginer le
nombre de victimes c'est ça donc la
parole libère la parole et c'est vrai
que ce livre était ma dernière chance
d'être entendue je voulais aller mieux
je vais de mieux en mieux alors moi je
te trouve est-ce que je te soulage
écoles oui je suis soulagé vraiment je
voulais le compte était venu
c'est vrai que tu étais même
physiquement oui j'étais là c'est vrai
qu'on perd voilà c'est vrai là je me
sens revivre la boîte de continuer à
patiner c'est ma passion je retourne
dans mon club aux français volants ils
m'ont ouvert les portes donc je
retournais pas payante et un poids qui
est parti il ya un poids effectivement
qui est parti et le fait d'aider les
autres ce genre de témoignage d'audrey
qui me dit quelque part tu m'as sauvé et
j'ai reçu énormément de témoignages qui
disent grâce à toi sahara on va mieux on
s'en sort on en a parlé on a porté
plainte et c'est vraiment le message que
je veux véhiculer et je me bats pour
toutes les victimes aussi contre la
prescription parce que ça nos agresseurs
sont dehors mais le mien - il a été
éloigné heureusement des patinoires il
ne sera plus dans les patinoires mais
tant qu'il ya cette prescription et bien
nous on vient emprisonné quand même
toute notre vie on va mieux nous sommes
des survivantes mais à cause de cette
prescription nos agresseurs sont dehors
encore bateau et ça je me batte pour
thonon couple est victime pour voilà
j'appelle le gouvernement aidez nous
s'il vous plaît aidez